Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Cucina Buttata, oggi ho
pensato di riproporre una ricetta
abbastanza famosa ma che solitamente
compro sempre al supermercato. Sto
parlando dei nachos con la salsa
guacamole. Ho trovato questa ragazza che
si chiama Zeina di fanpage e lei usa un
procedimento molto molto semplice che
richiede i seguenti ingredienti
farina di mais, un gattino...no, dentro c'è dell'acqua
olio di arachide. Teoricamente dovrebbe
essere molto semplice come procedimento.
200 grammi di farina di mais, finissima, senza
glutine addirittura. Mazza, nachos per un
esercito, senza contare che stiamo
girando abbastanza presto,
quindi ci metteremo a friggere questi qui
Ma poi come le classiche famiglie messincane no?(Chef Rico)
Beh esatto!...Aggiungiamo 200
millilitri d'acqua, da far vedere che
li abbiamo misurati... Enrico tu non me lo ricordi mai...mettiamo il grembiule
200 millilitri d'acqua. Comunque ti rendi conto che i nachos
sono solamente acqua e farina di mais
No ragazzi c'è un errore, bisogna
aggiungere un po' di farina
fidatevi. Si ma...
Deve essere giallo precotta, ma è precotta? Gianmarco! Eh (Mario). Questa farina
di mais giallo precotta? E' gialla (Mario)
Non scaricare la colpa sulla famiglia eh (Mario)
Non ho messo il cucchiaio di sale
Forse un po più d'acqua serve
Mettici il sale nell'acqua (Purci)
"Mettici il sale nell'acqua". Chef Francis. Sto aggiungendo altri boh d'acqua
Il fatto è che...
Gianmarco, Gianmarco! Eh (Mario). Questa
farina, erano tutte senza glutine?
Era l'unica che c'era al mais...Non è che il glutine aiuta a compattare? Quello sicuro (Mario)
Grazie mille, la prossima volta con Gianmarco
cercheremo di fare i Baci Perugina con
dei sassi al posto delle nocciole. Si può stendere
"Papà! Ti prego! "
"Come ti sei permesso?". Sembra la pietra di Fantaghirò. E' una palla
de sabbia. La piazzo tra due fogli...e
andiamo a stendere
Secondo me una volta che riesci a fare i triangolini e buttarli in padella (Mario)
Eh grazie, una volta che riesco a mangiare, è finito
Oh sei preciso eh!...Mazza bravo (Rico)
Non si sollevano
Ma la stai capendo? (Rico). Ci sono i sottotitoli...gyun kada. Certo
Stiamo per cambiare la ricetta
perché io questa qui me la voglio portare
a casa, non posso chiuderla così, cioè non è corretto nelle
persone che credono nell'alta cucina
Però una
fonte attendibile di ricette da gli
stessi quantitativi di zenya...si...però io temo che l'errore sia "precotta per tortillas"
Cioè una farina particolare penso (Purci). Cioè non è che so un esperto di farine sinceramente (Mario)
Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova puntata di Cucina
Buttata, oggi cercheremo di fare i nachos fatti in casa
Abbiamo bisogno di farina di mais. Ma è farina
di mais Gu (Rico)
Si in realtà non è proprio...però si si shhh...inquadra inquadra
Farina 00, sale, e poi servono semini che
potete immaginare qui sulla mia mano in
questo momento che servono
fondamentalmente per dare quei puntini
neri che a volte vedete, che voi invece
immaginerete nella mia mano. Ah l'olio
pure, serve dell'odio. Ma olio di arachide ci va? (Rico)
E' un olio, è olio. Riproviamoci io ci credo. Amico come
ti chiami tu? Mischa. 150 grammi di farina di mais
Ok. 75 grammi di farina normale ed
improvvisamente non siamo più gluten
gluten free. Gluten. Ma lei fa così ? (Rico). No questo è il mio metodo. Ma allora che cosa dici! (Rico)
Un pizzico di sale, semi, polvere, ok
Si li ho già messi semi
Due cucchiai di olio. Facciamo ad occhio...pieno...pieno. Ok quindi dobbiamo ora unire tutto
quanto finché non è bello amalgamato.
Amalgamato (Rico)
Non ti preoccupare era la lavastoviglie (Purci). Acqua qb ok? Il discorso è
questo, acqua qb. E' un altro livello,
sento che proprio abbiamo fatto bene
E questa secondo me è una grandissima
allegoria nella vita, cioè quando ti
rendi conto che stai sbagliando qualcosa
cambia, non stare lì a cercare di
migliorare gli errori. Gli errori non si
migliorano, gli errori fanno migliorare
Questa è la nostra versione,
diciamo la versione fusion, fusion
L'incontro tra Zeina e Shina. Nadia...Chi è Nadia?...Questa qui da cui hai copiato la ricetta (Rico)
Quella che parlava indiano si chiama
Nadia? O Nisha? Si un po' un sasso però
credo che sia una cosa positiva lo sai?
Fai quella giusta però, il cerchio...Sono un po' altini Gu
Sì ma o erano un po' altini oppure non c'erano
Ci riproviamo? Porca miseria la difficoltà di sto coso...Ora che è molto sottile vediamo un
pochino come ridiamo. Questa è una pizza. Forchetta
Ci stanno? Sisisi (Rico). Uno, due. E' un'altra
roba sì sì sì, cioè nel senso anche se
Gianmarco non ha preso la giusta farina
in questo modo abbiamo quello che ci serviva
Comunque tu scarichi sempre la colpa su di me per i tuoi fallimenti (Mario)
Però c'è da dire che adesso si sente l'odore del successo (Rico)
Sì, ma sai perché? Perché non sento odore
di Gianmarco. No si è rotto questo
Gianmarco!...Se beccate le dosi giuste ,cioè
divertente da fare in compagnia, con la
consapevolezza che a 1 euro trovi un
chilo di nachos ma non sai che cosa c'è
dentro, qui invece sai che c'è una farina sbagliata
Che cos'è? (Rico). Non ne ho idea, forse la sedia dietro di
te che si alzava o si abbassava. Se eri tu
sei un automa, sei un robot. Si ma sti
coltelli sono letali. Ma te li ha arrotati
l'arrotino? Si. Come li arrota i coltelli? Come non lo so ma so che altro arrota, forbici
Forbici da seta.Ma non c'è tipo quel
macchinario che gira, capito quale? (Rico)
Le palle?...Te l'ho detto! Perché la sedia viene compressa dal tuo peso e quando ti alzi fa aaa
Ti giuro sto pensando che è la tua
faccia...Le luci! (Rico). Le luci! Ragazzi quando si
frigge cioè questo è l'olio che si mette. Però come dice Tanya dice "Non da sommergere tutte". (Mario)
Chi è Tanya?
So cascate per terra? (Mario)
Shhhh...Aspetta sicuro dentro c'è
qualcosa, è ovvio (Rico)
Shhhh
Quelli verranno bolliti...Quant'è la cottura di un lato? (Rico)
Finchè non diventano belli dorati. Welà (Rico)
Che bello tutti insieme, sono venuti a
trovarmi altri cugini. State per mangiare
dei nachos...Sono qui apposta (Bob)...Mi sa che rimarrà molto delusa
Sta frittura è alta così. Ah potrestri fare il Guacamole adesso che stanno a frigge...però poi (Rico)
...poi ti ritrovi degli stoppini per le porte...Li ho cotti troppo?
No? (Rico)
De che sanno? Di pietra (Rico)
Mettiamo in ordine questo casino e
passiamo al guacamole. Allora gli
ingredienti sono un avocado, un lime, un
pomodoro, dello scalogno, sale. In realtà
ci vorrebbe il peperoncino quello lì
grosso che tu tagli ma Gianmarco ha ben
pensato di prendere del peperoncino
secco. Io ringrazio Manuel di
giallozafferano perché mi sono ispirato alla sua ricetta e
quando dico ispirato diciamo che la sto copiando per
intero. Mi raccomando ragazzi avocado bello maturo
Una tecnica che ho visto fare
per tagliarlo bene è quella di tagliarlo
direttamente dentro
l'avocado, almeno questo è quello che fa
Manuel, io solitamente uso un cucchiaino
e lo tiro fuori, il problema è che poi lo devi
tagliare e sporcare. Invece questa qui è
una cosa ancora più da pesaculi, quindi
l'adoro. Così, così
Tagliate per bene, poi fate...A questo punto cucchiaio
andate sotto e incominciate a tirare via
tutto. Prendiamo a questo punto il lime
veloci veloci prima che si ossidi, lo
massaggiamo. Questa qui è una cosa che mi dimentico
sempre di fare. Teoricamente si massaggia
per far uscire ancora meglio il succo
Mazza ma così tanto ce ne va di lime? 10
grammi di succo...Hai caricato ve?...Uno intero? (Mario)
Noo...vabbè è giusto. Nell'infobox ragazzi mettiamo tutti quanti gli
ingredienti perché non sennò si fa un casino.
Sale, pepe che non avevamo. Pepe
Ah sta scendendo... Na carbonara ho fatto...e
schiacciamo
Usa il pestello del mortaio (Bob)
Il pestello del mortaio? Un'ascia anche mi va bene
Sicuramente ce l'ha il mortaio Pierfra (Bob)...Chef Bob sei stata bravissima
Stai schiacciando qualcosa? (Devi). Assolutamente nulla
Dopo pochi giorni dovreste riuscire ad aver ottenuto un
composto morbido con qualche pezzetto ma
perché l'abbiamo scelto noi di tenere
qualche pezzetto. Aggiungiamo lo scalogno...tritato, un po' di pomodoro...tagliato a
dadini. Aggiungiamo a questo punto un
peperoncino messicano tagliato proprio al coltello
Mado (Rico). Madonna! (Mario)
Molto probabilmente tra due secondi mi ci faccio il bidet
con queste stesse mani. Vabbè a voi
piace tanto il piccante no? Un po' d'olio.
Praticamente non ho detto minimamente quali
erano gli ingredienti all'inizio del video, ho aggiunto il pepe, ho aggiunto l'olio
Mischiamo...no?
Mazza che bella la salsa! (Mario)
E questo dovrebbe essere il
risultato, direi a questo punto di fare un
assaggio, nachos fatti in casa con
guacamole fatta in casa
Nono lo vedo con una faccia soddisfattissima...la salsa com'è? Buona quella (Mario)
Abbondate di salsa
Questa è buona
Allora
...la salsa guacamole è squisita, e qui mi fermo...Volete provare? Questi sono
veramente grossi, però la salsa l'hai fatta bene. Non mi rubare il condimento...Sono strani, sembrano
delle patatine fritte. A me piace. Cioè nel senso non è un nachos (Rico). Qualunque cosa sia è
buono però. Bravo Chef Devi. Il guacamole è pazzesco!
E questi come sono?...Non mi
interessa il tuo parere. No Davide torna qui, Chef Devi
Allora questo è tuo. Grazie caro, ma sicuro Chef Devi...
Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video, nell'info box metterò tutti
quanti gli ingredienti che sono stati
utilizzati sia per i nachos che per la
salsa guacamole. Come sempre vi invito se
doveste provare anche voi a fare i nachos
o la salsa o quello che vi pare
a taggarmi su Instagram, mandarmi
le vostre stories, le foto, quello che vi
pare. Iscrivetevi a questo canale
attivate la campanella
se non volete perdere i prossimi video
Noi ci vediamo la prossima domenica
sempre con un'altra puntata di Cucina Buttata. Ciao